if you're listening right now and you're
like uh social's such a drag it's
because you're in a drag mindset and the
Algos and the people you follow are
following you you know what my social
looks like sunshine I'm being dead
serious you know what my Algos look like
sunshine in the world of the momentum of
Darkness right now sunshine you know why
I choose to fight for positivity but I
refuse to not be grounded in
practicality which is why I've always
thrown curveballs love everybody it's
all awesome [__] eighth place trophies
what Gary what what eighth place
trophies lead to entitlement and fear of
losing and it [__] up kids so like it's
kind of that juxtaposition practical
positivity is something everyone needs
to add more look at every person you
follow are they triggering your
insecurities for their own self-interest
are they trying to put love into it so
that you go on and do your thing watch
look for it